Good morning Hank it's Tuesday.
So you may remember back in the halcyon days
of 2007 when I was young and clean-shaven
and the state of Illinois had a budget, our
YouTube channel had a resident mathematician,
Daniel Biss.
So Daniel and I became friends in 2003 just
after he got his PhD from MIT; that's a lot
of letters for a numbers guy.
I'm sorry, I want to apologize to my friends,
my family.
I am deeply ashamed of that joke.
But anyway, when I met Daniel, he was a math
professor at the University of Chicago, only
he didn't have to teach any classes and he
also wasn't required to publish, he just sort
of had to think about math.
Daniel was a good person with a good life.
So, Hank, you can imagine my surprise when
Daniel told me one day that he no longer wanted
to be a mathematician with a tenure track
professorship at the University of Chicago
and instead wanted to be a member of the Illinois
State House of Representatives.
I mean, Daniel is charming and funny and intelligent,
but he did not strike me as a politician,
least of all an Illinois politician.
One ought not generalize about a class of
individuals, of course, Hank, but between
1961 and 2013, most of the people who served
as Governor of Illinois were later imprisoned
for corruption.
Not a couple, not some, most.
But Daniel seemed to genuinely believe that
government service was noble and important,
so back in 2008, Nerdfighteria helped raise
money for his campaign, and he lost, but then
in 2010, he won, and then in 2012, he was
elected to the Illinois State Senate.
Daniel is a Democrat, but he's widely respected.
In fact, I once met a Republican member of
the Illinois House who told me Daniel Biss
is one of the smartest people I have ever
met, only he didn't say people, he said a
curse word.
Daniel is also one of the smartest curse words
I've ever met, and he turns out to be a really
effective politician.
He passed a hugely important retirement savings
bill in Illinois, he passed a law banning
so-called "conversion therapy" for LGBT youth.
He's also been a big advocate for privacy,
especially when it comes to technology, like
he passed a bill saying that police can't
use surveillance drones without a search warrant,
and I have to say, he's kind of made me believe
in politics again, like, in an age of American
ideologues, he's this practical and sensible
person who genuinely wants to make people's
lives suck less.
And refreshingly, he doesn't use inflammatory
rhetoric.
Meanwhile, the state of Illinois is careening
toward disaster.
See, I know how to use inflammatory rhetoric.
Illinois has over 100 billion dollars in pension
debt, which is unique in the country.
It also has a poor credit rating, and it's
currently operating without a budget, which
has led to, if I may quote Daniel, "An insane
patchwork quilt of incomprehensible nonsense."
That's not inflammatory, that's factual.
Like, one example of this incomprehensible
nonsense, the Illinois State Museum has closed
because of budget cuts, but all of its employees
are still going to work and getting paid.
Neither the Republican governor nor the Democratic
leaders of the state legislature are at all
serious about the kinds of reform that are
needed to end Illinois' decades of fiscal
mismanagement.
If I were Daniel, I would find all of that
so annoying.
Daniel: When I find something immensely frustrating,
I ask myself, "Am I frustrated because something
is broken and corrupt, or am I frustrated
because I don't get to be the Emperor?
And every time it's option B, I remind myself
that's actually a positive thing, because
this way we never have a Mussolini.
People of goodwill need to be willing to accept
that slowness.
Otherwise, the process gets taken over by
people who are deliberately trying to steal
from it."
John: Alright, so Daniel is now running for
comptroller of Illinois.
If you don't know what a comptroller is, don't
worry, I didn't know either, until Daniel
told me.
It's basically like the chief financial officer
for the state.
And I want Daniel to win, not because he's
my friend, but because he's a smart and independent
voice, and he's also very good at math, which
is a useful skill for a comptroller.
But here's the thing, politics, in some ways,
especially local politics, are run by money.
Running for comptroller, a job I'd never heard
of until my friend ran for it, costs millions
of dollars.
So if you wanna know what's wrong with American
politics, just remember that campaigns for
Illinois State Comptroller cost millions of
dollars.
So I'm going to do a fundraiser for Daniel
next month.
In fact, it'll be my last public appearance
before VidCon.
The tickets are $40, which I know is a lot,
I'm sorry, but everybody who goes will get
a copy of An Abundance of Katherines, signed
by both Daniel and me.
I hope to see some of you there.
You can also donate to Daniel's campaign directly
at danielbiss.com, and regardless of your
political beliefs, if you're lucky enough
to live in a country where your voice matters,
I would encourage you to get involved in the
political process.
One thing I've learned from Daniel is that
good, honest people in politics really can
make a difference.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.